so i was two and a half years old when
we moved
from brazil to venezuela correct caracas
venezuela
and uh that was because you got promoted
within pepsi
to not just all of brazil but central
america yeah actually brazil had was
was part of the latin america group
and i reported to a boss in buenos aires
and
when we moved to caracas they divided
that into
two halves and i had the half
that went from the border north port of
brazil
up to the south border of mexico so that
was an upgrade
that was called north latin america and
yeah that was a significant promotion
significant promotion so uh
i'm two and a half years old at this
point and um
i'm i'm speaking english with you guys
yeah i had been speaking portuguese in
brazil
and now i'm in caracas venezuela so this
is where i learned to speak spanish
correct
in nursery school correct yeah i went in
with the maids at home
right and uh when was it the first
day of nursery school the mom picked me
up and they said there was a real
problem
oh yeah i uh
what was the problem well i forget the
word
tremendous tremendous
at that time our spanish you know was
okay but need needed work yeah and
tremendo
thinking about it my mom shares up to
pick up yeah and
we both thought that was really good i
mean that's right and then we asked
somebody
uh you know i mean you presumably
weren't there
mom picked me up yeah and she told me
the story afterwards she told me the
story when
the teacher said what steve is trying to
say his mom said hi
how was my son oh he was tremendous yeah
but nobody
there spoke any english so right all the
communication was in spanish
sir like you need to know that your son
is tremendous
thank you okay my mom's really pretty
happy about this
she comes home to brag about it yeah it
takes a good news back to ted yeah she
comes out
you know hey how about that my son's
tremendous guys
and uh the the spanish speaking friends
said hey you know that's not uh
tremendous like a storm
i get like a hurricane like uh yeah like
like a piece of [ __ ] but not [ __ ]
cool
so that's you at three years old like
what could you have done
in there you know right can i just tell
you how [ __ ] up my new tour is
it's completely multimedia legitimately
x-rated there's legal waivers all over
the venue because i'm
actually worried about getting sued and
i don't give a [ __ ] man
because it's gnarly and it's all the
stuff i wasn't allowed to do on jackass
so get to my [ __ ] website stevo.com
and get your tickets man especially with
this movie coming out dude
they're all gonna sell dude so hurry up
while you can get seats